will you commit to making sure that
there is a peaceful transferal of power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens
president trump has some concerns about
the upcoming election
can you give a direct answer you will
accept the election look
you i have to say that you will
absolutely accept the result of this
election i will look at it at the time
he thinks the democrats will corrupt the
voting ballots and
if that appears to cost him the election
he might not give up his power
so easily he will not give up power
under no circumstances will he give up
power
he intends to serve at least two more
terms
but how would that work if a sitting
president loses fair and square
can they still dispute the results and
refuse to leave office
does the government have a peaceful
solution for this
or would he have to be removed by force
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if president trump loses and refuses to
leave
many people think that the military
would be the ones to force
a defeated president from office i
promise you i'm absolutely convinced
they will escort him from the white
house
with great dispatch but that's not the
case
if there are any disputes over the
outcome of an election
it's up to the u.s court system and the
u.s congress to resolve them
not the us military but
what if the president doesn't trust
their decision either
would it take a civil uprising to get
him out
or is there a more sophisticated process
already in place
only 22 of americans believe
that the upcoming election will be free
and fair
there are many reasons for this
skepticism including potential
corruption
and tampering of the process and
even without those the united states
electoral system
is already over complicated and has lots
of room for dispute
just look at 2016 where the candidate
with the most
votes did not win the election
one of the main reasons that the system
is so complicated
is because of something called the
electoral college
in most american elections individuals
are elected by
popular vote but the president
and vice president are chosen by
electors
in the electoral college every state
gets a number of
electors based on their number of
members of congress
there are 538 electors in total
and each state's political party chooses
its electors
a presidential candidate needs at least
270 electors to win the presidential
election
when someone votes for president the
vote goes
into a statewide tally in most states
all the elector votes go to the winner
of that tally
the constitution does not require the
electors to follow their state's popular
vote but
many states laws require it however
there have been cases where electors
challenged the laws
and voted against the popular opinion
with all this considered you can see how
this electoral process
has lots of room for controversy
so let's say president trump loses fair
and square this november but
he says the results aren't clear enough
for him to accept
what would happen next
[Music]
well on january 20th he would skip the
inauguration on capitol hill
and instead would declare that the
election was rigged
the u.s military would salute president
biden
meaning that trump could no longer
command them to do anything
if he tried to and some members obeyed
him
they would be tried and convicted on
mutiny and sedition charges
foreign leaders would cut off relations
with the u.s ambassadors
awaiting instructions from president
biden
biden's acting attorney general would
write up
arrest warrants for president trump with
charges of
criminal trespassing at the very least
trump could remain in the oval office
but
it would soon be cut off from power
but this is all essentially a best case
scenario
[Music]
in reality things could get a lot more
complicated
as civilians might get involved if
trump says that the election was rigged
his passionate followers might
take to the streets we've seen people
explicitly declare support for trump
or use his slogans during acts of
violence before
so what would stop some of his more
extreme supporters from
rallying together to fight back for him
this time any act of violence here
could further separate the public into
democrats and republicans
even more severely than they are now and
if the civilians don't trust the
government to fix things
could this lead to another civil war
well
let's hope it doesn't get that bad
regardless of who wins this election a
lot of people are going to be upset
but what's important is that the us
finds a way to move forward
to become a more unified nation
wouldn't it be nice if we had a time
machine so we could just
skip into the future and see how this
all plays out
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
hey don't leave us just yet we wanted to
let you know that we now have youtube
membership
support our show and receive awesome
perks like exclusive wallpapers
and shout outs click on the join button
below and choose your tier